the FA and several Premiership football
clubs and Sheridan bird is Emil and
based journalist and serie commentator
who was at last night's match or Jared
and I'll start with you first what was
it like I mean was it as torturous there
as it was to watch over here it was
because Italy I'm usually for them were
making the play they were being
aggressive they were being proactive but
the Swedish team had a plan and it was
very effective they packed out their
defense and they just would not be
knocked down they built a yellow wall
and Italy couldn't get through it or
round it and at the end of the match it
was nominees I was expecting some anger
I was expecting you know colorful
language but they were just none the
fans around me because this doesn't
happen to Italy the first time for 60
years so they were thinking well what
happens now we know this kind of thing
isn't you know something we used to so
it was more cases that I was shocked at
how numb everybody was the headlines
like apocalypse a bit overdoing it in
the country that's had a couple of fatal
earthquakes during the last decade no
because it was actually in line that the
president of the Italian FA Carlota
Vecchio used he said a few months ago
maybe four or five months ago when there
were a few wobbles he said no we will
qualify for the World Cup
if we don't it would be a pocket that an
apocalypse so he was suggesting that
come on it's not going to happen if we
don't well that really would be the end
of the line but the apocalypse has
happened to quote the famous film it is
Apocalypse Now well Alex let me bring
you in at this point
I mean how on earth did Italy get in
this mess they didn't play the
qualification game properly they had
mixed results in proper tournaments in
the European Championships they did well
in the last World Cup they didn't but
they lost a lot of friendlies which
meant that they were relegated to pool
too which meant they had to play Spain
and as soon as they drew in Italy they
knew they were playing for a playoff
place they thought everything would be
alright on the night it wasn't so no
Italy no Netherlands no Chile I mean
what on earth is is going to do for
FIFA's revenues - three very big
footballing nations missing well a lot
of the revenues are already in place
because the main source of income is the
broadcast revenues and they are really
organized some years in advance you have
to go back to 1998 for a poor World Cup
so FIFA of forecasting revenues are over
five billion
it won't undermine that the only point I
would make is that unlike Premier League
football for example where the
transmission goes to the highest bidder
FIFA is curtailed to some extent by
having after having in certain countries
free-to-air transmission the other major
deficit for them will be sponsors and
they've had a hard time some sponsors
have not renews some key sponsors others
have not been announced yet there are a
long way behind what happened at the
last World Cup and the other problem of
course not only FIFA's image but
Russia's image why so Russia themselves
are having problems getting national
sponsors but will it undermine the event
is a supporting spectacle as well the
fact that Italy in the Dutch on their in
Chile no never because because Brazil
are there in Germany are there and Italy
haven't punched their weight recently
the Dutch punched above their weight at
the last World Cup they they will be
missed but the World Cup always has a
number of surprises and one of the joys
of the World Cup is to watch people who
don't expect go back to your your Pele
reference he actually forecast a number
of years ago that an African country
would win the World Cup so now perhaps
it's their time he never gets it right
dear old Pele does he Sheridan
where does Italy go from here I mean
I've seen a lot of attacks on venturi
the manager I've also seen some people
blaming Antonio Conte for walking out on
the national team and joining Chelsea it
may be nice you know put the graphic
down it's got nothing to do it this time
it's not his fault
as for I just want to react to something
Alex said I think Italy will be missed
at the World Cup not so much for what
they do on the pitch but the drama when
they're at a tournament it's so exciting
the the drama the complaining the
tension they leave it to the last minute
so I agree that then on the pitch they
haven't been impressive in the in recent
yes but what they do off the pitch is
always fascinating because they love the
they love the drama as for the future
obviously been daughter has to go
although he hasn't resigned yet I think
he's hoping for a payout is hoping to be
fired because his contract runs until
July so you know he's got a contract he
signed it in good faith so I think he's
a he's waiting to actually be told to
leave and give it and pay up which
hasn't gone down massively well here
with the fans but if you talk about the
actual on the pitch future this is a
good young generation of Italian talent
I don't think it's a case of throwing
out the Bambino with the bathwater there
are good young players but it just
against Sweden they got the tactics
horribly calm and sweet and got theirs
completely thanks all right Sheldon lost
word to you Alex who's gonna win Brazil
Germany Brazil check playing it safe
there Alex or muscle attitude or iover
two best teams all right Alex fin
Sheridan Berlin Milan good to see if I
thank you